[Music]
aleppo has become the apex of horror oh
[Music]
sure at its most horrific extent of the
suffering of people we're going to look
back on this and we're gonna be ashamed
of what we let happen in Aleppo the year
is 2011
this is Aleppo Syria's commercial
capital home to over 2 million people a
heady mix of sheer Sunni and Kurd the
Arab Spring is spreading across North
Africa and the Middle East
[Music]
and the first stirrings of uprising are
being felt here it being a huge hub of
anti-assad support it is the key city
that you have to take if you want to
sort of bleed away that support
metaphorically and physically not only
is it commercially very very critical to
the lifeblood of the entire Syrian
economy but it is the hub of the north
it is the main city in the north and
from there if you control Aleppo you are
able to quickly in terms of a military
conflict move on to other smaller towns
and cities Aleppo strategic importance
means both sides in the conflict
President Bashar al-assad and the rebels
who oppose him will not stop fighting
for it or killing for but despite for
continuous years of bombardment
President Assad has failed to win the
decisive victory he craves and needs
but now a major intervention is changing
everything and even by serious bloody
standards we have not witnessed the
devastation that is now being unleashed
on Aleppo and her desperate people
[Music]
Russian warplanes flying beyond the
reach of rebel missiles are helping the
Syrian Arab army to pound Aleppo into
obliteration this is al oppose
apocalyptic nightmare now
these families fleeing the fighting have
been caught in an artillery strike
lifeless bodies litter the streets the
carnage is witnessed by traumatized
children at least 20 people are thought
to have been killed or injured in this
one attack alone - oh okay ma'am I'm not
sure this devastation
top but Nana will not let them a
shallow-water well no he made it up
fella
let's see Meritage she believed husband
a man lucky this was live at times the
show of a freshwater but they're comin
in for the sick and wounded help is
running out
[Music]
nearly all the doctors and surgeons who
have braved Aleppo's long war have gone
or a dead well there are no hospitals
but there are about seven doctors left
now and I'm in contact with all of them
every day dr. David not is a war surgeon
he's one of the world's bravest but
decades he's given up his time and
personal safety to save lives in the
world's most dangerous conflicts
including Syria a few minutes ago
gunshot view to than somebody shot in
the nose even when he's not in Aleppo he
leads a team of surgeons through their
operations by Skype but that's had to
stop I was doing a Skype operation with
my colleagues in M 10 in Aleppo which is
one of the underground hospitals where I
worked in myself we try to and very
successfully repaired a man's jaw but
then two days later the hospital was
attacked and it may have been a
coincidence but it wasn't a coincidence
that two days after that the hospital
was attacked three days after that it
was attacked again and on the fourth
attack the hospital was completely
destroyed with a bunker-busting bomb and
that is not a coincidence
[Music]
sometimes I often think to myself
whether the coordinates of the Skype
conversation that we were having in
London probably were picked up because
it was an absolute direct target on
exactly the same coordinate of the of
the operating theater the targeting of
hospitals is a deliberate strategy
nowhere is safe from Russian or Syrian
army bombs Russia acts in a way which is
pretty indiscriminate and so they are
able to achieve strategic objectives
that Western forces probably couldn't do
because of our much stricter rules of
engagement so the type of warfare that
Russia uses also enables our said to
make much quicker gains then perhaps if
he was backed for example by a Western
act this push by regime loyal forces has
forced thousands to risk their lives and
flee caught in the crossfire and left
without an option stay and surely die or
brave the bombs and bullets and stagger
to safety according to Syrian state
television these people have praised
President Assad soldiers and their
Russian allies for saving them from
certain death there are some who are
desperate to escape but they don't trust
the regime
our she mañana Hoffman Baba Melanie the
other wooden hammer than here oh he's
here managed to make head as bad an
assault on ultra share Ramu plasma
Nvidia the Potala family did escape we
met them as they arrived frightened and
exhausted in Maria in the outer suburbs
of the city they told us the famine and
daily bombardments had become too much a
shower with new topology on Heather in
new media toward any further mahalo told
us yourself Nevada chillin she never
been devastated we are in quadrant
Midland Avenue new one on me sheffy
kool-aid noir FEMA message renamed oh la
la la Culebra Belgium Burma what will
digit daddy apparel been Olivia
nutricula
our individual out adorable though Vivi
we cannot order to serve their madman
you know all my Sophia Hoffman Audrey
Whitaker for
to be part of the international
community that is watch this complete
failure of Syria's children we've
watched children die in Aleppo every
single day we've watched as the cedar
tightened and no food has got into them
convoys of aid have been bombed convoys
have been turned back it does feel like
we're going to look back on this and
we're going to be ashamed of what we let
happen in Aleppo Aleppo speak fair the
West will continue to stand by and watch
as a city is slaughtered the killing
here is being hastened by events a world
away the issue of course now is that
because of Aleppo strategic and symbolic
importance and of course the fact that
there is a new president coming in
January I think the Russians have made a
calculation that if they retake the city
before president-elect Trump comes into
office then they can present this as a
fait accompli and say to the United
States hey look this is the strategic
situation on the ground like it or hate
it
accepted Assad staying he's got control
of the major urban centres and therefore
let's think about doing a deal with the
regime rather than consistently opposing
them the world has abandoned Aleppo but
dr. Ngoc can't rest until his small team
of medics can find safe passage from the
hell they're trapped in who continues to
put daily pressure on the Russians the
Syrian regime and the United Nations to
find them and others a safe route out of
Aleppo
[Music]
it's likely no other conflict has been
recorded so intensively and perhaps it's
this that has led to the inertia
[Applause]
unimaginable horror has become
imaginable but now as we watch aghast at
the last throes of this dying city we
must remember the fall of Aleppo comes
with the heaviest of costs somebody of
some powerful leadership quality really
needs to get in and sort the problem out
if that doesn't happen then I'm sure
that the majority of the people in
Aleppo will be killed and that would be
the biggest blood stain on all of us
forever and I don't know how we're going
to look back on this in a year or twos
time and say that we did nothing to help
the people in East Aleppo it is
absolutely a crime worse than I can ever
imagine
you